thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a freestyle
wild ride with Stevo we've got Harry
Mack he's the biggest name in freestyle
rap period hands down and what an honor
it was to talk to him not only do we get
a glimpse into the business of Harry
Mack into the lifestyle of Harry Mack we
get custom made rhymes about things that
I just needed rhymes for okay find out
what they are and enjoy this episode but
let me ask you if you're enjoying this
episode properly and by properly I mean
with a nice clean button because dude I
don't have to tell you Valentine's Day
is coming up and are you going to be
full of love on Valentine's Day or are
you going to be full of [__] on
Valentine's Day it's a simple question
because most people are not properly
cleaning their buttholes and the way to
do that to properly clean your buttholes
with hello tushy hellertushy.com this is
where you get bidets that changed my
life they got all different kinds you
got your entry level you've got your
entry level with uh temperature dial and
you've got the hello tushy Ace which is
a whole toilet seat with the remote
control the the seat heats up the water
heats up you got front back vibrate I
don't know if it vibrates but it's the
most amazing thing I love it it's my
favorite sponsor we've ever had on the
podcast and if you go to hellotushi.com
Stevo not only will you get 10 off your
order you get free shipping too that's a
big deal it's my favorite product I've
ever promoted on this podcast it is a
bidet which just pressure cleans your
butthole and man is it satisfying to our
ground was a perfectly clean butthole so
go to hellotissy.com Stevo to jump on
that deal now and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Harry Mack yes yes
you met Scott Randolph yep and Vincent
Emperor yes about that yeah Dad
now you gotta blown out background
because you didn't [__] put the thing
on the windshield dude he had a blown
out a butthole from this last week
but in any case all right man thank you
for doing this no thank you for having
me man you're a legend bro I appreciate
this well I appreciate that and you're
well on your way I just uh watched a
bunch of stuff on you and uh the
takeaway was it is not a controversial
statement to say that Harry Mack is the
best freestyler alive today oh man well
thank you bro I appreciate that would
you agree with that uh that's a heavy
statement you're not allowed to agree
with that okay the person yeah like I
don't like to say that you know what
Jackson's or Michael Jordan's like I'm
the [__] goat everyone here's the
thing here's the thing I'll remind you
of my buddy uh uh diving Guy Brian
gloley says if you're good at some says
people are who are good at something
we'll tell everybody people when people
are great at something everybody else
says it I like that I like that too I
like that too you know I when I'm
rapping I like to say that I'm the
greatest you know because that's the
language of hip-hop the bread to go show
and all that but um in conversation I
would never say I'm I'm the goat or
anything like that because I'm you know
I'm still looking up to you know Nas is
still alive you know I'm still looking
up to people like that people like Jay-Z
my favorite rappers you know and and in
my eyes I still have a a big gap to fill
before I'm at that level right of
artistry so but uh but I appreciate it
though for sure man what I would think
here it's uh it's it's evident
um you started on YouTube in 2016. yeah
that's right and it was a pretty pretty
slow climbing up like putting together
the following didn't really pop off
until uh like until the pandemic come
yeah well there were two kind of uh
pop-off moments I guess I started making
videos at the end of 2016 and it was
really only because my friend uh who's
like a jazz piano player
um kind of convinced me to do it you
know he knew that I was a freestyler and
uh he knew that I was dope but you know
I wasn't really making my own content or
or pushing for a career I think just
because of my own insecurities at the
time and stuff like that right and what
insecurities would you have when you can
[__] spit out [__] that like fire you
know what man a lot of people say that
um I don't know I think you know so my
background is in jazz I'm a jazz drummer
right and then pianist it uh just a
little bit just a little bit not not
professional level but I make beats and
stuff so I play enough piano to make you
go to school uh USC USC and and there
was a formal music training there yeah I
did a jazz studies I have a jazz Studies
major as a drummer uh from USC so I did
my undergrad there for four years
um but you know as a jazz drummer you're
always in a supportive role for the most
part you know I'm not the leader like
I'm not the front person up there
singing My Singing my heart out or
whatever I'm just showing up you know
tell me what to wear tell me when to get
there I'll bring my drums and I'll
support your vision you know whoever the
band leader is and so I just got really
comfortable being in the background like
that and when it came to the freestyle
thing you know it was like every time we
were at a party the cipher would pop off
and I would do my thing and all the
homies would be like bro that is [__]
crazy
uh cypher's just a bunch of dudes
rapping okay a bunch of people free
stuff
you got some songs right
I don't think I have heard poked the
[__] there were a bunch of them okay I
I had a lot of uh pretty wild songs but
just not much on the talent end of
things after you graduated from USC did
you uh did you work as a drummer yeah
yeah I gigged around La as a as a
drummer but I never had a lot of success
at it yeah I was playing a lot of like
really shitty like 50 bar gigs you know
and things where when you add up the gas
and the travel you're making less than
minimum wage kind of situations always
being told like oh you know please play
quieter you know you're disturbing the
guests you know you know [__] like that
like real soul sucking kind of stuff so
while you were doing that yeah you
presumably had to work a side job yeah
well I you know what I was piecing it
together like barely full-time music but
that included teaching drum lessons
right you know to kids that didn't even
want to be there and didn't practice and
[__] like that and yeah it was just like
and taking every little gig I could
every once in a while you get a wedding
gig or something okay this pays you know
200 all right hell yeah like and just
barely putting the rent together
when it uh was the type of gig that kind
of gave you more creative license would
you throw rapping into it occasionally
occasionally yeah yeah in certain
situations uh if it made sense you know
uh I would I would get up and Rhyme or
something occasionally I would rap while
I was doing the drum beat and stuff like
that right which is really hard that's
cool I wondered too if uh if you would
show up with your own uh kind of PA
system with the mic oh you know what not
usually it would usually be like if they
already had a PA at the club or whatever
or that maybe there was a vocalist who
brought the PA something like that
um weddings like oddly enough you know
like the wedding the infamous wedding
gig which is like also kind of a
soul-sucking gig oftentimes you know but
uh everyone would get drunk and then and
then somehow it would it would be become
known that I can rap and then then it's
always like oh go you know get up on the
mic and rap you know and then you're
freestyling about the bride and groom
and [__] like that and calling out
everybody's outfits and things like that
so yeah you know every once in a while
it would have a little outlet but it was
always this thing where it was like
this thing that I can do that that so
that was so kind of special that I was
so passionate about didn't really have a
way out like a formal way out right it
was like leaking out in these in these
odd moments when it could you know
whether that was at a house party with
the homies or randomly at somebody's
wedding and every time it happened
everybody around me would be like you
should [__] do that like that's crazy
you know you should you should lean into
that and I just didn't have the uh you
know the confidence to do it at that
time and really become that person so it
wasn't until the end of 2016 when I made
that first video that I kind of the
first video that I did with my friend
Jacob that he was for his channel was
this that they're going through Venice
no this was driving down Sunset
Boulevard it's a lesser-known video
because it's not on on my channel okay
but um basically he he was trying to
promote his Jazz album he had remixed
one of his jazz tracks into a hip-hop
beat and to do some creative promo he
was like bro can you freestyle on this
beat we'll drive down Sunset you know
you can rap about all the passing
scenery and things like that to prove
that it's improvised yeah and uh we did
that in like 20 minutes grab some lunch
I forgot about it and like a week later
I woke up from a nap and my roommate at
the time was like bro you're going viral
right now and I was like what the [__]
are you talking about and she was like
you're this video of you freestyling is
number one on Reddit videos was that the
first time that you did the going down
the street to prove that it's legit
Freestyle by rapping about the
surroundings it was the first time I
filmed it right I freestyle for hours
and cars driving around but never to
make content you know that dude that is
a pretty Bonafide way to prove that it's
uh yeah and then it's freestyle yeah
well people in the comments were like oh
he mapped this out he mapped this one
you wrote this song Perfectly he timed
the lights you know I mean it's crazy
yeah yeah it's crazy so so now that
you've really like had this meteoric
rise are there different components to
your to your rapping like Summer's
freeze job but then you've got like an
album that you're working on that's all
super polished and yeah uh so I have
like a project that's out called
contents Under Pressure that I did a few
years back where there's some like
written material on it
um
but for me I I love improvising like I
love freestyling and even when I'm in
the studio uh making songs
I think I find for me like the best
process is to improvise you know and
even if afterwards we pick the best
chunks and rearrange things maybe fix a
couple things up or re-record segments
and sections it's like for me I can't
access the best stuff unless I'm
improvising all right you know it's hard
for me to sit there and write is it true
that on your YouTube channel there are
videos that are eight and nine hours
long and you're freestyling for the
entire time yeah there's a 10 hour one
actually yeah I'll tell you I'll tell
you how that happened uh so what
happened was during the pandemic I did a
lot of live streaming like on YouTube
and twitch and stuff like that and there
was a big audience for it at that time
because you know everyone was home
watching content you know if people were
you know depressed and people needed
some kind of uh something to sit down
and enjoy so
um a lot of people were showing up for
the streams and so my YouTube channel
was growing a lot so we hit 500 000
subscribers and I was like all right you
know what I'm gonna do a marathon stream
five hours for 500k subscribers you know
so we did the five hours and that's nuts
yeah which was crazy at the time that
was like the craziest thing I could
imagine that I'm gonna go for five hours
straight you know and so what happens is
toward the end of it like you enter this
crazy kind of like Flow State almost
like you know you don't even feel your
body type of thing you know what I mean
you're just like totally just like in it
your mouth's just moving whatever it's
like it's almost like a tribal kind of
[__] Vibe you know
um
exactly exactly you're speaking in
tongues you're speaking in tongues and
so when I'm in this state of like you
know borderline delirium then someone in
the comments like jokingly was like Hey
I can't wait for six hours for 600k and
I saw the comment and I'm like [__] it
we're doing it six hours for 600k all
the way up to a million seven hours for
700k I like committed to it on the
stream without having my full wits about
me probably you know it wasn't the
smartest thing necessarily but and the
irony being that that just made it all
so popular the next thing you know you
are hitting a million and you've got to
do 10 hours well the benchmarks came
faster and faster which was the scary
thing like I thought I'd have a few
months before we had to do the six hours
but it was like next month six hours
next month seven hours few weeks later
we did the eight and then the nine and
then the ten so I did all of those
lengths of time for each of those 100K
landmarks from 500 to a million I mean
it's got to be a cliche question but
like how did you prepare to pee you know
why I asked that because if you're not
peeing a lot you're not drinking enough
water I know that because I drink plenty
of water and I drink liquid death now
let me tell you about the meteoric rise
of this company they started out like it
was a joke what if we made water called
liquid death because we're so upset
about the world being ruined by plastic
so their motto is death to plastic and
man this company has just become a very
big deal available on Amazon at pretty
much every convenience store Target
Whole Foods I mean you name it you're
seeing it everywhere and get on board
because they're saving the world they're
the most environmental company out there
they donate 10 of their profits to
ridding the world of plastic you know
that big plastic island in the middle of
the sea they're tackling it and they've
got the greatest merch I I love this
step I love this company and if you've
never bought apparel at liquiddeath.com
Stevo
do it now because their merch is epic
and if you're a first time merch buyer
at liquiddeath.com Stevo then you get 20
off your order right now so drink water
drink liquid death get it at the retail
stores get it on the website and hurry
up and buy liquid death merch like this
killer severed hand candle that they did
as a collab with Martha Stewart telling
you this stuff is amazing so go to
liquiddeath.com Stevo for 20 off your
first apparel order right now and let's
get back to it
no I should have worn a diaper man I
should have I wish we had had this
conversation before that that would have
been hilarious the depends diapers they
really just soak it up or you don't even
yeah those I mean those are adult
diapers right they're made for uh for a
grown paid for 10 hour freestyles that's
right you could have done a whole
sponsorship man if I had my business
[__] together first dude yeah I could
have gotten the sponsor but not so at my
old house
um where I was living at the time was
this little back house and the bathroom
was like just the first door off of the
studio so I dipped into the bathroom and
took a piss once so while you're pissing
are you rapping about the fact that
you're pissing it
that also I should have done
I paused the wrap for 30 seconds to go
pee you know it was sort of like it was
forgiving you know so it wasn't like I I
wrapped like non-stop bars like I would
do verses and and pause for four bars
and say you know like when it made sense
like when the beat ends and a new beat
comes on right I would get into the
rhythm of the new beat and continue but
I never took a break like I never
stopped for more than 30 seconds really
you know to P was probably the longest
break that I took okay yeah so you're
crazy yeah like if you do that for 10
hours I mean the the OCD or whatever it
is like I I know you're gnarlier than I
am Stephen we're doing the trick shots
and I'm tapping out at like a hundred
times you'll just keep doing it until
you get it and you're like 300 400 times
and then when I do get it it wasn't good
enough
and that's what it would have hit me
because there was a thing that you said
where you were like doing a a bouncy
ball and you're like this is for my late
hamster Doyle and he said it a hundred
times and then it started [__] with
my head
go in the bed because I was like
starting to crack I was starting to lose
it and you just hear him in the stairs
going this is for my late hamster Doyle
and he said it like three
doing it for 10 hours like are you what
the [__] going on that's a great
question that's a great question no I
mean after the 10 hours I was like I
don't need to do another Marathon stream
uh ever again probably because the
physicality of it is the challenge it's
the it's the throat and the vocals that
could potentially [__] it all up it's
not so much the mind but what's
interesting is with freestyling I think
the reason I love it so much and have
loved it for so long you know since I
was 11 12 years old when I first started
trying to figure out how to do it is um
it's sort of like a access point to you
know Flow State or like what people call
getting in the zone or whatever where
it's like
the thing is it's it's so challenging
that it requires my full attention uh
but because I practiced it for so long
I'm able to accomplish it so it's like
consistently rewarding you know it's
like every new word that I get thrown or
grab and work into a line it's like if I
can pull it off it's like [__] yeah you
know in that moment it's like yes and
then it gives you this excitement and
this energy to kind of like continue on
that path and and so it sort of becomes
this thing where you have blinders on
and all the external noise and all that
you know all the voices in your head
that are going on all day and all that
just sort of gets muted and you just
have this one singular Focus that's
consistently rewarding and holding your
attention and kind of pulling you
forward so
um I don't know I guess I guess the 10
hour stream was like an exercise in the
depth of Flow State you know like how
deep can I really get in there and stay
there it's crazy yeah are there any
words that's hard to rap I was watching
Eminem on Anderson Cooper
nothing rhymes with orange
the word orange like what would you oh
yeah well now everybody can ever since
that clip came out you know Eminem I
mean he he I think he comes up with like
20 options or something that rhyme with
orange that became a really viral kind
of clip yeah are there any words like
that for you that's like tricky if
somebody calls out you're like [__] oh
definitely definitely I mean
um you know usually there's a way to do
it like uh with you know there's these
things called slant Rhymes which are
just words that sound like they rhyme
even though they don't perfectly rhyme
right which you can utilize those to uh
you know so that's the thing with like
orange you know there's nothing that
perfectly rhymes with orange but what
Eminem was saying is you can change the
way you pronounce it to be a little more
orange
in storage or and for me like even just
if it's one syllable orange you could
rhyme it with perform or torn or scorned
you know words like that that sound
similar enough yeah so you can use those
but there there are some words that
would always [__] me up just because I
would get like mentally confused like
arithmetic for some reason whenever I
saw arithmetic
I would think of like I'm with my [__]
yes
you're right good ones man
[Music]
yeah like a broader vocabulary I don't
get that I don't do that Eminem said he
does that yeah I kind of don't get that
see because for me the thing is I
wouldn't remember any of that [__] like
that's just not the way that I learn you
know so um I could sit there and read it
but it would just be like in one ear out
the other you know the way that I get
sort of uh comfortable with different
words or sounds is by utilizing like
using them in a rap you know uh and I
have to know it and sort of like
organically use it so like if people
give me a word to Freestyle about and I
have no idea what it means that's when
I'm gonna get stumped you know as long
as I know what it means I can work with
it but I saw you uh rapping
um how do you even say it like as a dog
from the perspective of a dog yeah from
the perspective of a dog and if we were
gonna ask you to rap
um
this this dog Wendy yeah I found her in
the streets of Peru amazing I like to
call her uh the fresh princess of
Hollywood because like she came from uh
you know it's almost like on the streets
of Peru I was born and raised
I wonder if we could if we could rip off
that her name her name's Wendy okay
Wendy from the streets of Peru Yeah
Wendy from Peru is her Instagram handle
oh hell yeah shout out to Wendy from
Peru yeah we could do that definitely
yeah dude that's cool man yeah I think
you know I'm not I'm like sensitive
about it because I just hate the idea of
like sitting down for an interview and
someone's like okay now you're gonna do
this now you're gonna do this
they're down like he asked if we could
if you could rap on the show yeah all
right I would love to I would like and
then let's fire up some Wendy [__]
bars let's do it let's do it yeah Paul
sent me a beat to play one of his musics
do you want to do like a fresh prince
but I don't know if the copyright would
be an issue no no I wouldn't I mean
whatever dude but yeah but fire up a
beat yeah I gotta beat uh how heavy no
the bar is pretty high we did this with
the island boys oh oh my God
this was a setup man this was a setup so
I don't know how to do this but uh Paul
sent me a beat called [__] ass [__]
maybe he's just calling me that but uh I
I guess
oh yeah here we go
okay
I never hesitate off top I rap Devine
right now imma take y'all back in time
you'll see me in the Hollywood Hills
yeah that's true but it wasn't always
easy I was born in Peru I remember back
then living in the streets no one to
give me treats I was always getting beat
yeah no one telling me to sit no one
cared about my existence yo no one was
aware I was struggling in the streets of
Peru believe bro until I finally
connected with Stevo yeah he was out
there on on tour I was barely surviving
eating scraps out the sewer I was having
visions of living just like a god yeah
wanted to transcend from just a dog yes
Stevo crossed paths with me and said I
got something for you called Mastery if
you can Master these tricks you can earn
this tree and you can move with me to a
place much more sweet Stevo looked me in
the eyes said it'll all be good we leave
in Peru we bout to go to Hollywood yeah
and now I'm out here my Style's live I
get to sit on the couch for the Wild
Ride hey yo I knew I would progress to a
dog gone fast no longer a dog I'm on the
podcast living to a whole brand new
degree imma tell you a secret between
you and me I know it looks like I'm
sitting here calm and quiet but my heart
rages inside it it's a goddamn Riot no
I'm blessed is to be this far along the
only dog that can rip bars on songs I
crunch the treat now I'm sitting
listening to Mac H Mac off the tip
unscripted with
[Applause]
appreciate it when does the words hit
your brain actually like how how far
ahead are you thinking like a sentence a
two ahead like yeah yeah just Wendy's
got a song I'm sorry I
forgot to say Wendy in the bars though
we might have to do another one at the
end here sure
um yeah that's a great question so I'm
only thinking um slightly ahead like
maybe half a bar ahead what really
happens a lot of the time so I'm
utilizing this technique I call it setup
punch line but um other people probably
call it other things but essentially
what it means is I'm working backwards
from a Target word a lot of the time so
like give me a random word
um
that's great so Philippines you can say
butthole yeah okay so either one you
know it doesn't matter what the word is
but you know when I was first starting
out and I didn't really have much
technique you would just say the word
and then like pray to God that you find
something that can rhyme with it and it
makes sense so I'd be like yeah
Philippines and I'm a real regime you
know whatever whatever you get lost and
you fall off you know it's out of
control and so
um the technique that I use now is
called setup punchline where if you say
Philippines rather than just say it
first reactively I'm going to set it up
with something that rhymes with it so
that I can kind of like slide into home
nice and smooth so if you say
Philippines I might say yo Harry Mack I
grabbed the mic and I kill the scene I
get props from LA to the Philippines I
got a lot of spirit and I love Soul
other rappers when they spit they sound
like butthole you know what I mean so
rather than say butthole first and then
love and then try to find something
rhymes with it you're utilizing this
structure and you can just kind of daisy
chain those Rhymes together that way and
sort of have control over it but is it
easier to like is it easier to connect
those words uh because before when you
didn't have that technique where you
were you still that smooth no it was
just harder it was harder and I ended up
sort of like being a lot more repetitive
you know you would just kind of fall in
one of the challenges with being an
improviser whether it's freestyling or
playing jazz or anything is you create
these habits you know and so it's like
every time I rhyme I would say kind of
the same types of things you know the
same word would come to mind listen yeah
yeah I'm on a mission you know because
you can kind of sit there and rhyme just
just with sort of like filler wraps like
forever listen I'm on a mission repping
my division causing Collision I go
inside like an incision what it is
better mind your Biz I'm signing all
these kids you know or whatever whatever
and but if you want to incorporate
random words uh which is what I'm more
known for doing or incorporate random
imagery
um it's really helpful to have that set
up punchline structure to kind of like
guide you through it and help me kind of
smooth it out but it took a long time to
figure that out you know to to sort of
Master that style and be able to daisy
chain them together but I'm not really
thinking that far ahead it's like as
soon as I'm finishing the first the
first couplet like if I was going to do
a rhyme about fan there's a fan right
there it's like off the top hmac is the
man got head spinning and I know I'm
gonna end with fan and right at that
moment then I'm looking to rap about
liquid death or look for my next Target
so it's more of this kind of like as
you're finishing the line you're
reaching out for the next Target you
know wow if that makes sense and then
you're not copyrighting your music or
you're so that decision to do that on
YouTube where people like don't do that
like people or were you like no no I
want everybody to use it I
Drew Mac is a clever guy for taking that
approach and you know what else is
clever and I want everybody to use
whoop the whoop strap it's the most
sophisticated Fitness tracking device
known to man all of my favorite people
are using it Joe Rogan Bert Kreischer
Rich Roll I mean dude the list goes on
and on and on and the insights that you
get into your sleep your recovery your
your
respiratory abilities and and dude it
tells how oxygenated your blood is now I
mean dude this thing knows if I'm riding
a bicycle it knows if I'm riding a
skateboard and I've been skateboarding a
lot and my whoop is really
congratulating me for it telling me how
many calories I'm burnt how much time
I'm spending in my optimal heart rate
zone I just love it man and I love
keeping track of my sleep because when I
when I know that my whoop is going to
tell me how I slept I find myself trying
to get that better recovery recovery and
when I get that killer recovery I know
that I gotta put myself through more
strain on that day it really just kind
of guides me to being healthier and let
me guide you to being healthier by
pointing you to whoop.com that's
w-h-o-o-p.com where if you use the promo
code Stevo you will get 15 off at
checkout and the new whoop 4.0 band it's
not only waterproof but the Charger's
waterproof you never have to take off
the band or just slide the charger on
top and the charger it's charging while
you're under water I mean this thing's
incredible I love it you're gonna love
it too so go to whoop.com and use the
promo code Stevo for 15 off at checkout
now let's get back to it well right like
I saw something indicating that uh
there's so many people making reaction
videos yeah to Max Music that that's
actually what's building the fan base so
he gives them content to react to and
they give him awareness of of uh his
skills yeah exactly yeah so for us like
there's this huge community of reactors
on YouTube right they watch yeah it's
fun and uh so they'll watch people's
content and react and just straight up
react to it and and build a following
that way because they have great
personalities or they have you know
great insight into what's being done and
things of that nature and so uh my
content is great for the reactors
because yeah I'm not doing the content
ID thing or flagging it or you know I'm
not oftentimes what happens is whoever
made the content originally will
monetize the reactors content right
which we could do like we could flip a
switch basically and then you know I'm
sure that we would get a lot more money
right away if if we did that but at the
same time there probably wouldn't be as
many reactors that were so eager to
react to my content because it's great
for them they get to monetize that and
then you know if a reactor's video gets
a million views or whatever that's great
for us too you know then when we go on
tour there's more awareness more people
are buying tickets so who's us
oh like me and my team you know yeah
yeah yeah uh so uh yeah I have a team of
of uh I guess about eight people now
that um you know help me and and uh you
know editors and you know my manager and
people who work with me to to make my
content and run my business and all that
yeah it's epic so do you uh do to worry
about these books coordinates The Improv
yeah yeah yeah yeah we went on tour we
did the first sort of like legit I would
say legit tour just this past year in in
um we did 32 gigs in the U.S and then uh
10 shows out in Europe first time out in
Europe doing doing shows how did it go
in Europe dude it was crazy Europe was
nuts yeah it was nuts
um it was so fun uh because the US tour
was also fantastic
um but it was interesting because I was
doing a lot of the shows in comedy clubs
right
um which was just because you know we
had a contact at uh at Levity Live which
is the company that owns all the Improv
clubs and some other you know comedy
clubs across the US and they were just a
fan of what I do and we're like hey man
if you want to route a tour
any of these venues are open to you you
know you can get in here and do a show
and uh you know it's not a comedy show
uh it's a music show but it's yeah it's
it's who knows what it is right it's
like I mean it's uh Watching You
Freestyle
it reminds me a little bit of uh like
Jeff Ross yeah where he roasts people on
the spot yeah it's all improv yeah yeah
and I wonder if you put like uh a
roast spin on it you know yeah yeah like
a freestyle of roasting Rhymes now it's
funny because people will email me and
be like roast me bro just roast me you
know because people like to get roasted
you know some people like to like to get
roasted but the thing is man like I'm
I'm like honestly I'm a nice guy
I can't do I can't force it like I just
don't like I don't like making people
feel bad either yeah insult comedy is
not me it doesn't come to me because my
thing is I'll I'll I'm not good at
knowing where that line is to where it's
all good and it's all fun if I'm like oh
be mean it's so foreign to me that I'm
gonna say something like truly [__] up
I feel like you know
yeah that's not funny at all that's just
like offensive in me and I was like dude
you know I just made a video with Wee
Man where uh we were trying to compete
to see who could get the better
skateboard footage okay and I was like
yeah but yeah back on you know bag on my
tricks like uh you know like
and and then I come and say see the
bridge we made and he's like making fun
of me for everything except
skateboarding I'm like
but uh but I kept it all in yeah yeah
yeah but I was just like why are you
attacking me
exactly exactly man now my [__] is like
my [__] is like uh you know it's it's
almost like it's not straight up
compliment it's not like a compliment
thing they're they're battle rappers
that will do compliment battles for fun
you know where they say like the nicest
[__] they can think of to each other
which is pretty hilarious but um it's
like I'm rapping about your outfit and
uh you know those are dope sneakers and
stuff like that I'm usually like I'm
making people feel heard and seen you
know in in all reality I do think that
that's a big part of why my content has
been successful is because people want
to people want to feel heard and seen
you know what I mean and in my case it's
like I'm not rapping uh about you know
my stuff all the time I'm rapping about
the words that people are giving me you
know or what other people people are
wearing and it involves them in it you
know and it's crazy the magic that that
has I never would have known that it
would be that powerful that I mean
people [__] just like go from a
regular straight face to just beaming
Smile as soon as their jacket gets
Incorporated in the rhyme or whatever
it's such a it's such a simple thing but
uh it's it has this amazing uh Power to
connect I think you know have you found
yourself in any uh rap beefs
oh man that's a great question uh not
not really not any like legit rap beefs
I could not I can imagine someone just
like like hating on you throwing shade
at you and then like you just kind of
don't think oh that's interesting and
then you don't respond that's my that's
my Mo just don't respond don't give it
any energy you know what I mean because
it's like
yeah and it's the same thing like with
the comments and you know the trolls and
the people hate I used to respond to
people you know okay all right that's
how you feel you know [__] you too
whatever and uh it never it never it
never gets you anywhere you know what I
mean it just steals your energy away
okay we probably don't want to draw any
attention to what Scott Randolph has
done recently
what's that
well well you're talking about the
negative comments he'll go in like he'll
respond to the most negative person and
be like hey let me send you a bottle of
hot sauce and the person will like
almost invariably like right back like
wow now I feel like an [__] yeah like
some guy we did a shoe giveaway for some
some Nike Dunks or the black and yellows
in um and then on that video I was
looking through the comments and some
guy just [__] on me dude for like he's
like God get this [__] guy out of
here and I was like you know what did
you won and uh I want to give you the
shoes and then he did he didn't respond
I was like are you sure you don't want
him like dude thank God you didn't give
him the shoes oh well he deserved the
shoes dude because he's really hurt
inside right but but it's so true that's
so true
this is not inviting of course it's [__]
anyway invariably they were like [__]
now the guy goes
you won me over dude I'm gonna get a
fork and eat my words I'm so [__]
sorry another guy was like hit me up
like two days later I was like dude I
gotta be honest like I thought about
this for two days and he's like dude I
was an [__] like I am so [__]
sorry and it's like see that's all they
want well you know yeah and that's half
the time if you do call somebody out or
or just or say something nice like hey
man I hope you're all right you know
because these people are like you're
probably hurting inside to some degree
if you're taking time out of your day
you know
to comment in a negative way on
something that you know you don't have
to have anything to do with if you could
choose to Walk On By but but they're
commenting negative about the people but
it's like but you're following our
Channel exactly so like why would you
follow our Channel if you hate me that
much or if you talking [__] about Steve
or whatever like why would you do that
and I think the fact that when you then
reply with hey you won and then they're
like coming back like yo that was a dick
thing to say I think the reality is
people don't expect any kind of response
they feel like you're you know up here
somewhere unreachable or to whatever
degree you know you're an influencer or
whatever it is you know you obviously
have a career
um
and uh and Vinnie's new but Vinnie's
killing it too oh yeah I love Vinnie
here dude yeah there have been comments
uh saying that I ate Paul for breakfast
that's amazing
it's wild the phenomenon of like just
people being negative but like you were
right like yeah people just want to be
seen and heard yeah that's why they're
like because they probably aren't yeah
exactly they're not getting attention
anywhere else that's that's a way that
they're reaching out to try to get
attention and when you come back you
know from a place of love and from a
place of kindness then they're like oh
[__] you know what was I doing I mean I
do think that's the best way if you're
gonna reply reply that way you know if I
see somebody at the show you see
somebody at the show like they're like
dude I love you on the podcast it's like
the negative comments they would never
say that to your face ever oh yeah or
like people talking [__] to UFC fighters
like oh you [__] [__] it's like dude
you would never say that to them so why
would you do that on a fake page exactly
and not just that fact alone like I've
thought about that too and then you come
to the conclusion like oh this is
literally not real this is not real
because you wouldn't say this to me if
you saw me yeah you know so it's not an
actual this is not a real human
interaction this is some weird internet
[__] bro if we had coffee we'd probably
have a lot of similarities like yeah why
are you talking to me like that yeah you
know if I smiled and nodded while I
passed you in the airport you probably
not back you know you wouldn't say oh
you [__] suck dude I know you your
shit's trash you know yeah right I mean
I get rejected by girls too like it
sucks it hurts like we're all human we
all got trauma yeah yeah yeah so yeah I
just can't mess with comments dude yeah
I'm really pretty disciplined these days
about just not
like it used to get me but the YouTube
creator app because at the bottom of
like the dashboard you see like the most
recent three comments and I would like
just allow myself to see those three
comments yeah but all too often one of
them just messed up my day so I just
stop scrolling before I get there yeah
that's good that now I'm pretty much off
the comments myself too I haven't
actually been on socials like I haven't
been on a tick tock or or Instagram in a
few months yeah you gotta kill on Tick
Tock oh yeah yeah we're going crazy on
Tick Tock are you still uh are you still
doing Omegle yep yeah you didn't mention
them so I didn't want to bring them up
because when
what's going on with Omegle without oh
with Omegle yeah yeah so we do uh I have
a series called I pronounce I
mispronounced it Omegle so my series is
called Omegle bars that's how we say how
we say it but really I guess it's Omegle
bars but um yeah you know amigo right
it's like the video chat site matches
you with strangers on the internet you
know what could go wrong yeah oh that's
right
Chat Roulette or whatever you're getting
you're wrapping and some dudes jerking
off oh yeah lots of dudes jerking off
that happens oh that has happened yeah
yeah no not in the video like we don't
agree right but um you know it's funny
like I I didn't want to go on there for
a long time because I'm not the first
like Omegle content creator there's
there's musicians that go on there or
comedians or whatever it's just a good
way to interact with strangers and get
reactions from people who don't know who
you are right but uh people would say yo
your [__] would kill on Omegle you know
get on there get some words for the
freestyle and I was like man it's just
gonna be a bunch of dudes jerking off
you know because that's what it used to
be
but now I have uh they have uh like I
don't need that you know but um now they
have these uh sort of like comment
filters so you can type in basically
like a hashtag like what are you
interested in you know tv YouTube music
hip-hop whatever whatever and it
connects you with people with that
shared interest and for somehow for
whatever reason it does a really good
job filtering out the dicks so you know
like
uh we're on episode 80 of Omegle bars
and I've probably seen like 20 actual
dicks you know which is pretty that's
pretty good like for the amount of time
that I've been on there filming content
you know it's like do you ever do uh rap
battles with you know no I mean Dicky or
something
I think it's safe to say that if Harry
Mack takes on anybody at battle rap he's
gonna drop them like a bad habit and let
me tell you how to drop a bad habit
there is this thing called fume and it's
just incredible man it's super healthy
because you just breathes and you're
breathing in essential oils it's just a
really good way
to do a healthy thing instead of an
unhealthy thing and I get a kick out of
it man I I enjoy it I actually keep it
in my pocket all the time these days
because I genuinely enjoy it and I know
it's not bad for me at all plus if you
get the journey pack from
trifum.com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use the promo code
Stevo then you'll get the journey pack
with the version 2 theme plus three
original flavors and you get 10 off your
order if it's your first time ordering
and I know somebody who's got a habit
that they need to drop so
Let's uh you head on over to try
fume.com and use the promo code Stevo as
well Mr Vincent imperati all right
everybody I just want my Wild Ride
listeners to be healthier and happier
and kick those bad habits at
tritheam.com using the promo code Stevo
now let's get back to it no challenge
shout out to Lil Dicky though he's dope
I uh we watched his show not long ago
and I loved it
um but uh no I never I'm not a battler
you know it's the same thing I mean I I
was in a couple battles like in middle
school high school and college and [__]
like that
um just for fun but uh you know in terms
of like the professional battle leagues
and stuff like that people see what I do
and they're like bro you would crush it
on the battle scene you know you should
do that but it's the same thing as
before it's like I'm not really into the
whole dissing thing and also it's it's
not really a freestyle thing anymore the
the battle leagues it's like these dudes
are writing like incredible lyrical like
uh you know insane mind-blowing [__]
about their opponent you know you get
paired with an opponent you have a month
or two or however much time you have to
prepare like the craziest lyrical [__]
to destroy this person and it's amazing
what they do I respect it you know I'm
I'm a fan I watch it you know but um if
I went in there just thinking I was
going to go off the top and improvise
and go against these cats I think I
would get I think I would get torn apart
man because it's not really a freestyle
thing yeah you're like being all nice
and they're just like ripping you to
[__] yeah I'm like no kicks and they're
like
yeah but uh for shout out to all the
Battlers it is dope I am a fan of it
it's amazing what they're doing and I do
think it's one of the it's like a niche
where super high level lyric lyricism
kind of lives you know yeah yeah
have you uh
had interactions with Eminem no I never
have had interactions with them
acknowledged you on any level nah man it
kills me inside no no yeah yeah not yet
but that's Eminem you know he's I mean
he's he's one of the goats so
um yeah if that if that comes you know
that'll be amazing have you been able to
uh to work with any like super high
level rappers not really like in a in an
official capacity but I have had the
opportunity to Freestyle for uh some
really really dope people some big name
people yeah that was gonna be my next
question what's it like doing that in
front of Kendrick Lamar or Joey Badass
like dude I'm nervous like yeah yeah I
did a freestyle for Joey Badass on uh on
the cruise show in LA and then a couple
months later I did it for Kendrick Lamar
uh freestyle next to Soldier Boy and
some other people so
um yeah Kendrick man I was I was
[__] myself I was so [__] nervous
yeah because what had happened I mean
I'll tell you the story real quick um
I uh this was back in 2017 so I had just
had like my first kind of viral video on
YouTube which was me rapping in Venice
Beach the one you mentioned
um and so the radio station hit me up
and uh for the cruise show and they said
hey you know you want to come by and do
a freestyle did a little feature on me
and then as an afterthought when I was
on my way out the door you know Joey
Badass was coming in to do promo for his
album and they're like oh would you want
to Freestyle for Joey Badass if he's
into it you know I'm nervous inside but
I'm like oh [__] yeah yeah let's do it
you know whatever and so went in and
Joey was down shout out to Joey Badass
cause I feel like so many artists would
have been like ah random Youtube rapper
I don't know like I'm here to do promo
you know maybe not right right but he
was totally he was like [__] yeah bring
him in you know and he threw me words
for the freestyle the whole time and
that video went crazy and I mentioned to
um Jay Cruz and them from the cruise
show that like you know Kendrick was my
favorite artist of today you know
um and so a couple months later when
Kendrick was coming on they hit me up
and they're like bro come down do a
freestyle for Kendrick so I was nervous
as [__] because I'm you know he's one of
my heroes for sure you know I'm such a
big fan since 2016. yeah my alarm on my
iPhone is Kendrick Lamar no way which
what what song
I got a bone to pick yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah that's what it is
that's the joint yeah
come to me right away it's literally
like anytime I set my alarm
that's a good way to get the day started
too man you got bone to pick yeah I
never get bored of it like I have no
desire to change it like that's my alarm
and that's how it is that's amazing I
got a micro dick
yes sir that's all I got dude
she got a chick yeah yeah yeah I have a
girlfriend we've been together for a
long time five years five years we
worked together so yeah yeah and uh and
and the whole dynamic of of your career
is just like what does she do she's my
manager oh wow we work together yeah she
comes on tour with us cool um yeah she
and she uh kind of like runs a lot of
things on the business side so she's
like Sharon Osborne you're Aussie
exactly exactly that's it bro 100
um which has been like really dope man
I'm sure you know I'm sure it wouldn't
work out in every situation and it's
always you know people are always
curious like what's it like working with
your with your girl you know
um because we're together all the time
on the work tip and then you know we're
romantically involved obviously but for
us it's really dope man and um you know
we just are conscious of like making
space and stuff like that and right
having time apart as well and having
boundaries and things like that but um
it's just been really fun really
rewarding to kind of Build Together in
in One Direction right yeah yeah you
can't lie about how much money you make
anymore though that's the problem no
exactly yeah yeah she knows better than
me
yeah that's cool but it's cool too
because I'm very much on the um
raw creative tip you know what I mean I
and that's why I like freestyling
because I just like that flow State
thing you know I'm just like play a B
you know let's freestyle like that's why
I'm always down to Freestyle on a show
like this or anything I'm like I like to
Freestyle you know it's not you're not
asking it's not a tall order to ask me
to rhyme I'm waiting for the opportunity
to rhyme and so because I'm so on that
raw creative tip sometimes the more
managerial system based things are a
little more of a challenge and that's
kind of her world so it's a good balance
it's Scott and me yeah yeah yeah yeah he
can duct tape himself to a billboard and
I'll I'll uh make the phone calls and do
the paperwork yes 100 100 you need that
though right oftentimes you you see
those Partnerships I feel like right you
have to have somebody who fills in your
gaps yeah yeah without a doubt I'm I
feel comfortable with the fact that like
he can throw out the craziest [__] in
the world yeah and what I like doing is
I like to make it work yeah so like he
shouldn't feel held back from doing
certain things right except it's like
well maybe this legal thing might you
know but right I know I'm doing my job
if he can say the most [__] craziest
[__] yes and like uh I'm like okay how
do you bridge that Gap yeah yeah you
build the space around it so that it can
exist yeah yeah that's dope man I love
that I wanted to ask you a question
because I you know being the the drummer
did you ever see the movie Whiplash yeah
of course yeah how but that was like
Juilliard but how how intense is being a
drummer in college for jazz and like
he was he an actor yeah he was an actor
yeah yeah for theater I think yeah so
what's the difference between Juilliard
and like you're going to uh um USC USC
oh I mean Juilliard is like the most
prestigious art school in the world I
think so the USC's intense USC's good
yeah like the uh it's called the
Thornton School of Music at USC and some
people would say it's like you know it's
the Juilliard of the West okay or
whatever so so yeah it was a prestigious
program for sure
um and yeah you know there's there's
intense teachers along the way I mean
even when I was a kid in Portland like I
would have teachers at times that were
super intense you know uh yelling at you
and [__] like that I never had anybody
throw a chair in my head or anything
like that from the movie you ever seen
the movie Whiplash miles what's his name
yeah yeah that's unbelievable yeah crazy
based on a true story
I want to say yes just so you watch it
because it's not based on but it's uh
yeah nice
issues along the way for sure
um but nothing like that you know
nothing too crazy I had a lot of
supportive teachers too that's cool yeah
I just thought about it when I was
reading about you well there is that
sort of history and Jazz of like the
sort of uh you know that tough love kind
of uh relationship where like you know
there's stories from the Jazz folklore
of people throwing symbols at people's
heads and stuff like that and you know
that's kind of like how you learned
um but yeah crazy yeah
how many times since you've been with
your girl have you guys upgraded your uh
living situation uh only once man
recently yeah we got we we got a crib
together so before that we were living
in a tiny like a back house we were
renting a back house uh-huh
um so and when I first met her we were
each in our own apartment obviously and
so we went from the apartment we got the
back house which was cool we had a
little backyard and stuff our landlords
were super cool uh this older like
retired couple they were out of town a
lot and they were just dope
um so we stayed there for a long time
and and you know we were there during
the pandemic so uh that was crazy
because we were
both together working full-time and
living full-time in the pandemic in this
tiny little back house and for hours I
mean sometimes 10 hours continuously I'm
screaming freestyles you know in this
little room with the door closed she's
on a zoom meeting and people are like is
somebody rapping like are you are you
playing some music I'm just aggressively
in the bag talking about micro dicks now
but just going off rapping and uh so
that was crazy we were crammed in a tiny
space I mean I'm sure a lot of people
can relate to that from the pandemic
from feeling like that was a tester of
relationships it was and I I'm super
stoked on how my relationship got kind
of stronger hell yeah me too me too yeah
I mean if you if you make it through
that and you're still together and
you're good you know there's no way you
didn't get stronger right right so yeah
yeah but we recently got a house
together so which was a major upgrade
and exciting thing for us so cool yeah
congrats on that thank you so much
appreciate it do you have any tours
coming up or yeah we do yeah yeah going
I'm super excited we're going back out
this year we're doing the US and and
probably Europe again the U.S has been
announced Europe we're still getting the
routing together and everything but um
it's going to be crazy it's a uh much
bigger venues all music venues this time
I I loved performing in the comedy
venues it was dope to get in there yeah
but um for hip hop just the sound system
and the sort of you know the low end
that's necessary and I think there's a
certain energy with people standing up
and and uh rather than you know the sort
of the Supper Club Vibe for what I do
but uh I'm I'm super stoked man we're
going out end of March for a few months
yeah I went to a Beastie Boys show at
the Greek and it was all sit down and
they they stopped halfway through and
they're like you guys can get up and
like and then they did two more songs
they just build they're like oh really
this is [__] whack yeah yeah they
were just sitting there you can't just
sit there and watch the Beastie Boys no
you can't and it's funny because now
when I go to shows I'm like we get to
sit right like I love sitting now like
when I was in my 20s I was like standing
the whole time while now but now I like
to sit but for a hip-hop show man if
you're on stage and everybody's sitting
down it's just not the thing man you
need everybody standing up you need the
body swaying you know it's a different
type of energy yeah I mean it's
definitely different like like I'm the
the complete opposite like I uh I feel
like if my audience is standing then
they've got the mentality of like being
like at a rock show or like you know and
then like it's just disruptive in the
audience sure like I want I wanted
everything seated so that they're more
of the mindset like like oh I'm watching
a show like like you wouldn't scream out
[__] during a movie in a movie theater
right you know it's just not exactly so
I'm all about the seated I feel that I
feel that yeah it's it's it's uh
depending on what type of show is
happening the venue is so important
right yeah and the feel is so important
yeah so you're gonna have uh an opener
when you've gone towards the bigger
Vinnies we're not traveling with an
opener my DJ Spins for you know 30
minutes to 45 before I come out and then
uh we'll probably have local openers
that are sourced by the by the local
promoters and stuff like that so um
when uh when you go from comedy comedy
club you're basically
working on the weekends yeah when you go
to the bigger venues then you can do
like all week Longs yeah are you gonna
travel on a tour bus no tour bus no tour
bus
um we're gonna have a van like on the
ground that's bringing the gear to and
from but we're gonna fly uh just because
it's easier
um but uh yeah we're doing we're doing a
lot of shows we we one of the takeaways
from the last tour is like
you know it's tough when we're doing so
many back to back to back you know like
after the three shows like New City
straight to soundcheck do the show go to
sleep hop the flight like after three or
four in a row I'm just like I I need to
hibernate for 20 hours now you know like
that's right the tour bus kicks in yeah
like that must be dope tour bus like no
more airports yeah no more hotels yeah
you're just like you're just in this
this killer crib with your buddies that
just magically shows up where you got it
that's fire you know is that you you use
the two of us when you go out that's
still that's still been on the tour bus
lifestyle for uh
that's amazing but even before that
you've been in the RV lifestyle for like
three years before that too yeah we've
been doing this podcast in this RV for
uh coming about three years wow it's
dope man I love it I love it just
everything's all preset ready to roll
it's together man yeah and I don't have
to do [__] because Vinnie sets it up
hell yeah shout out to dinner yeah shout
out to Ben shout out to Vinnie dude
hey Paul dude
please can you take us out with a wrap
for the wild ride and a shout out to
Vinnie yes without a doubt without a
doubt yeah uh yeah but before we do that
is there anything do you have any merch
that we can promote do you have like uh
absolutely social media let's get let's
get the plugs and then let's get
everybody yeah man Harry Mack across the
board youtube.com Harry Mack I'm on Tick
Tock at Harry Mack official we have
merch on the website
harrymacofficial.com but the biggest
thing right now is the tour
um buy tickets to the tour Odyssey Tour
20 23 is going to be crazy it's a
totally unique experience it's mostly
improvised
oh you guys are on the list man
automatically you just reminded me of uh
my homie uh Mark raboutier yeah yeah
Mark revier yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's amazing man we did a video together
dude we did a live stream together him
and I thank God yes Dad he's he is one
mesmerizing cat oh he's amazing I saw
him at the Greek in L.A like just just a
few weeks ago Jesus he's up to the Greek
now yeah he's clearly rolling in money
he's [__] destroying yeah he's doing
the tour bus thing he's in there I can't
remember whose bus it is somebody huge
had the but you know that he bought the
bus from whatever
um but yeah no he's killing it he's
incredible man I'm sorry who is he Mark
rebeier he's like a loot pedal
improviser
kind of the thing that Reggie Watts does
I think they're they're contemporaries
absolutely yeah
she'll like set like uh his synthesizer
on a loop and then he'll do like a drum
beat like on a loop and once he sets It
Off
puts together like professional Quality
Music one man doing it all by himself
yeah and sets it and then starts singing
and like does it in improvise and like
while you're watching yeah it all
improvise yeah it's really cool yeah
it's amazing and he's a really Soulful
uh vocalist too like he's a funky dude
and he's hilarious and he's got the
comedy he's got the just the just
watching the way he moves and and oh you
can't you can't take your eyes off him
you can't take your eyes off him yeah we
got to do a live stream together
um that went really crazy on YouTube
um but it was fun I went over to his
house super nice guy too really really
down to earth dude really cool guy cool
yeah yeah all right sick so yeah so
where are people getting the tickets to
the tour that's at harrymac.com
harrymacofficial.com shows who's the
bastard that stole Harry Mack you know
what there's a shout out yeah yeah we've
got to find this [__] no oh this
is Mack that does uh video game scoring
I've never talked to him or met him but
it always gets mixed up on like Spotify
or apple music because you know it's
like it's all under the hood how they
sort things yeah so people will email me
all the time like bro I didn't know you
wrote the music to Slimer ranch or
whatever he did a soundtrack for some
game called slime video game scoring and
I'm thinking of like a judge who keeps
the score
did you know there's a little man
underground that does that manually
he's not like a little judge like a lion
judge
no no he wrote the music for some video
games or something like that so he's got
harrymac.com shout out to him he
probably hates me but uh shout out to
him yeah he's driving traffic to him
yeah that's true that's true hopefully
hopefully yeah Harry
mackofficial.com yes sir for your
tickets to The Odyssey tour 2023. that's
it baby you got merch at Harry Mack
official.com we got merch yep shop
harrymacofficial.com or just go to the
site there's a link there we got shirts
we got hats we got coffee mugs there you
go we got it all man awesome mansense so
that that and then there's nothing else
to promote not really just you know we
drop content every Friday on my YouTube
We post daily on all the socials I do a
lot of live streams
you're creeping up on what like 500
videos on YouTube some like that yeah
yeah we got we have 2.4 million
subscribers now so wow yeah yes congrats
thank you appreciate that appreciate
that yeah it's been a you know it's been
a a slow burn but
um wow
it's picked up like it's like a snowball
critical mass has happened oh yeah from
the from from zero to one million was
such a slower burn than the one to two
you know right I think that's how it
goes most of the time yeah
for me like it was like and then I just
Plateau dude I don't know why dude like
come on man subscribe dude
all right man so yeah let's bring it
let's bring it home with a wrap man
thank you so much no thank you man this
has been so much fun bro I really
appreciate it Stevo thank you guys man
it was really fascinating hell yeah hell
yeah let me get it beat up okay does it
recognize my face let's see you lost
some weight exactly it's like who's this
guy I'm I'm honored I'm complimented all
right here we go
so yo uh you guys want to throw me words
or something as we go just lob them out
all right
Vinnie huh yeah skin yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh there you go you already gave me the
rhyme
skinny vanny ah come on yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah never falling off
Mac is on the wind speed shouts out to
the homie skinny Vinnie he's not skinny
no more you best believe he was skinny
Vinnie until he ate Steve now he's just
slowly digesting one two one two Mike
testing uh H Mac all up on the Pod when
it comes to rhyming y'all know I'm the
freestyle god prostate yeah y'all know
that the God's great I got these rappers
in pain like a prostate yeah hmac
dropping more stanzas peace to anybody
with the prostate cancer hope y'all get
past that I know it's too common I'm
live over tracks people love the way I'm
bombing y'all know I'm about to leave
you scarred with this yo prostate that
can make it hard to pitch yeah hmac I
know I keep the style live it's a wild
Vibe when I'm right here on the Wild
Ride hey smack yo I Vibe with the plan
we know a whole podcast right inside of
a van H man you know that I'll be
Wilding boy I had to come here and
follow up the island boys he was like
after them you gotta get up I was like
[__] Stevo it's a setup
the mic and I swallow cats Island Boys
how the [__] I'm supposed to follow that
yo hmac I'm about to go mad you got that
contact though imma hit them for the
collab
y'all know I'm really about to blast
fast in the Snapback that's what Max
said matter of fact I got the speaker
inside my backpack do pranks with Rhymes
I'll be the lyrical jackass yeah your
whole vibe imma spoil it I was watching
y'all as kids [__] in display
toilets hey Jack I'm on it y'all know I
got that raw flare that was probably in
Portland up in Hippo Hardware I'm pretty
sure I know the spot down the block from
my crib when it comes to freestyles I be
running this shout out to Stevo he's an
ill Lord and you got the partner so that
you get away with the [__] billboard
duct tape no problems no legalities they
couldn't challenge me around for real
without no fallacy hit me with one more
we bout to send it home disguise off top
I'll be bending Palms yeah rappers in
the game can't get with this guy I'm
always authentic I never needed a
disguise rappers faking hip-hop is like
the fallacy most these artists be
wearing disguises like it's Halloween
I'm about to blow your mind when kicking
all these rappers they get cut in the
face just like a Jack-o-Lantern yeah all
about the cipher I ain't torn cause when
it comes to lyrics I'll be sharper than
the thorn I kill a rapper Dad I'm about
to make them on I hop up on the stage
and I'm ready to perform when I'm
kicking these throws just like porn
that's at least five words you can use
to rhyme with orange hey smash I'm on it
yo what'd you say poking the puss yeah
rappers get pushed away uh H man yo I'm
ready to push yeah we getting in it like
we poking the puss hmac I'm on it they
hate this [__] I know that song's gotta
be up on your greatest hits when I'm
rhyming I'll be on the winning spree but
I give no [__] like virginity yeah I'm
all appointed rappers they don't want
none stretch over tracks like latex from
condoms they say smack I'll be the
certified Rama and you better bet when
I'm rhyming for weather than vagina I go
up in the deeper my lyrics they get you
high just like reefer I'm on the part
just to make our Believers and every
time I rhyme I can't be denied getting
live with Steven wall up on the Wild
Ride let's go
thank you so much
thank you that's unbelievable I
appreciate you guys man I love it all
right
official yes sir
dude I really really enjoyed that oh man
me too man it was an honor to be able to
come on here sincerely how about that is
he a cool dude or what and how about
this uh candidly when this episode is
released I will be on tour
I'm supposed to be on tour with bam so
how's that going to go we'll find out
wish me luck
all right